welcome back well there is a big
showdown tomorrow night here in salt
lake city vice president pence and
senator kamala harris are getting ready
to debate
the contest taking on some new
importance with uncertainty swirling
around the rest of the campaign to say
the least
things will look a little different too
apparently there's a plexiglass divider
that will divide the candidates
and we're just learning that topics will
not be released ahead of time but there
will be
nine 10 minute blocks so in case you're
planning your time and your trips to the
refrigerator that's what you need to
know but i would stay glued to fox news
um jesse let me start with you pence is
a very good debater he has years of
experience in policy and politics
and he's been serving in this role for
four years that's very different from
kamala harris who has been in the senate
she's a
very accomplished person she is a
prosecutor but in the debates that she
had last year she was debating people
all within the same ideology
ideological um framework um
they were left of center to the very far
left how do you think she'll do when she
has to
be confronted with an opposing point of
view
well the bar is high because two-thirds
of voters think that if biden's elected
she will become president of the united
states and
pence is a good wingman like you said
he's a smooth debater he's got policy
chops he's been in the room
when every decision was made so i expect
her to be tenacious and just
throw a lot of nasty haymakers and
mostly focus on covid19
pence will not be interrupting so he's
going to have to grin and bear it
and then he'll have to defend himself
but then he'll have to throw counter
punches
you can't just play defense for 90
minutes and if a coveted attack comes
he's gonna have to turn that back into
an economic conversation about biden
harris
being for the shutdowns they're very
weak on that
he also has to turn every conversation
into that populist conservative sweet
spot
the no new wars manufacturing jobs no
sanctuary cities tough on china
lower drug prices if he can do that and
then turn it around
on policy on kamala because remember she
hasn't
answered any questions on policy for the
last
two months she's going to be shaky
she'll be well prepared
but there will be some shaky moments for
her
um greg i was thinking back to the
kavanaugh hearings and of course that's
where senator kamala harris really
i think she was planning to run for
president um even before that but i
think that's what really kind of get got
her into the news and into the headlines
the difference with pence from kavanaugh
is that kavanaugh was trying to be
confirmed as a united states supreme
court justice
he was trying to get through that as
best he could not argue too much but
having to defend himself this is a very
different situation for kamala harris
tomorrow night
i agree first let's this plexi glass
divider
it reminds me of going into a liquor
store in a really bad neighborhood
like when all of the cashiers are just
behind this thing and you have to slip
the money through
uh don't you send guys into those stores
i usually wait in the back of my limo uh
but you know i think um
okay so we're looking at these two
candidates and we're looking at it in a
different light because
it's a more significant debate given the
age of the candidates
pence looks like he could be president
he looks like he jumped off
he jumped right off a franklin mint coin
but she she seems still unsure of her
own abilities she still has that giggle
thing going
but she has one advantage and the
advantage is
trump trump is essentially a buffet of
eight different types of food
made out of trump so when she doesn't
have an idea
or a thing to say all she has to do is
run over to the buffet
get some trump augratin or some trump
fries
or some trump scalloped potatoes and
then come back
she will never run out of stuff to say
because all she has to do is go back to
trump and i think that's what she's
going to do
earlier today juan i couldn't remember
the name of the candidate that pence
faced off with in 2016. i was thinking
keane
kane it was kane senator tim kaine of
virginia how can
pence and kamala harris make this debate
a little bit more memorable
well dana you know so much of this has
to do with
is it going to move the polls is it
going to make a difference and i don't
know that that's the case but i think a
lot of people are going to tune in
because
as greg and jesse point out you've got
two 70 year olds one with covet and
there's a
real possibility that one of these two
people that we're going to watch
tomorrow night
could become president of the united
states a higher likelihood than normal
but what strikes me is again i don't
think that anybody's tuning and saying
i'm going to change my vote based on the
outcome of this
uh debate right now though what we're
seeing is that the polls had been static
really through the conventions and up to
that first debate but over the
last week since the debate wow those
polls have started to move
and they have not moved in a good
direction for president trump i think
now we have seen
that the debate really did have some
impact
and i'm not sure that this coming debate
tomorrow night will have that kind of
political impact but i do think it's
going to have a big audience
martha trump as as greg was saying
there's the trump buffet and trump runs
very hot
and pence runs a little bit cooler uh
biden reads
as a much older person and she reads as
a much younger person
um to biden so how you know is that an
advantage for her going into tomorrow
night
you know i i think that it is and i
think that they both have to be
more policy focused i talked to a bunch
of college kids in
utah here this morning and they all said
gee i just really hope that this debate
is more substantive
than the last one and i think this is
the opportunity for mike pence to really
drill down
on the achievements of the trump
presidency uh and to lay those out very
clearly and he's gonna have to hold
kamala harris's feet to the fire on
things like fracking
medicare for all she has flip-flopped on
a number of issues since she was a
primary candidate
and i would look for him to try to nail
down
where she really stands on those things
like packing the court which
to which she said absolutely when she
was asked about it just a few short
months ago so
um yeah i mean they are going to be the
more vibrant uh team i think
uh from what we have seen uh in the
prior debate
and uh the next debate is uh also one
that we're gonna be
sitting on the edge of our seats sport
at this point i think that pence will
definitely pivot to the economy
and prosecute that case very well for
the president okay